Wow.
Well go to your mom's house.
This is a narcissist and you end up
trying to say something.
I think so.
Um,
we still appreciate the,
uh,
the instrumental narcissist.
I'll be in Lewisville,
Kentucky,
Louisville,
Lucy Ville,
placebo.
Hey,
hey,
that's really good.
It's a good one.
You,
I heard the club closing the laughing derby.
Apparently they lost their liquor license.
Well that's really important for it.
I guess what my shows are still going to go on.
So I might be the last comic ever to play there.
You know,
get it straightened out.
Well then that's a pretty monumental thing and you guys should come out and see
Tom did the last week ever and Louisville come out and see it.
So I'll be there.
Man.
Home of Muhammad Ali.
Um,
let's see.
Then I go to fill her up.
Delphia finally for those four Trocadero shows,
spent a hundred tickets left and 21 show with tickets left.
Um,
then the,
uh,
you know where I'm going basically home west bombs,
beach,
West Ball beach,
west hairy balls,
beach,
Florida.
That is prob there.
I'm doing two nights,
only four shows.
That's it.
That's the best.
I love West Harry Palm.
Me Too.
And I love them all.
They're friends like that.
Bang,
Bang.
Um,
so I'm really excited to go back to west hairy balls,
beach.
Um,
then I'm doing new year's in mom,
Lando,
juniors,
eve.
And then if you would go to Tom [inaudible] dot com,
click on the tour page and you can see my 2017 tour laid out.
It starts as a amazed,
it's amazed.
It starts in Kansas City that I'm doing a,
an Ochsner date.
So I'm doing a local week and then,
um,
shortly thereafter the theaters start.
So great.
I'm starting in New Orleans and New Orleans,
New Orleans,
Atlanta and Clearwater,
Florida and Tallahassee.
That's my first weekend.
All right.
Atlanta.
Yeah.
Clear.
Farter clear farther.
Yeah.
What's Tallahassee?
Oh God,
I dunno.
Teller.
Hussy good.
Look at you clarified.
It was basically my tampon date cause it's like 20 miles or so apart.
Oh,
that's awesome.
Yeah.
So if you live in Tampa in Florida,
I'm basically coming across the bridge,
you know?
Yeah.
You're going to Washington,
Dick Holmes,
uh,
in December.
Right.
Nailed it.
Yeah.
Washington d district of Columbia,
December 9th and 10th.
And then I'm one of the best clubs in the country.
Jeezy it's,
it's the best dude.
It's such,
the audiences are so funny because they all work at the government.
They all work at the White House with President Obama,
Obama,
Obama.
Uh,
so yeah.
And then I'll be planning 2017 shortly guys.
Yeah.
You got some cool stuff.
Cooking.
Tom's ahead of the curb.
Yeah,
I'm ahead of the curve of spee.
I'm booked through April.
You,
you guys really got on your calendar quick.
They didn't mess around at APA,
did they?
We did add,
by the way,
we added a Minneapolis show,
Minneapolis,
some of these shows,
by the way,
we're not going to add,
so if you want,
I wouldn't wait super long.
No on like Seattle meet rattles going to sell out.
Lickety split.
We got a lot of mommies and meet,
meet Milwaukee.
We're not going to add,
so make sure,
make sure you get your tickets while you can.
Why not get tickets for toms to Gora for Christmas?
Hey Alec,
or your mate for your life partner for your lover or your parent or your
brother,
your sister,
your mom,
your dad,
whoever your pet,
your pet.
Bring your dog to see Tom Cigarette.
But if he's got to have his own seat,
he or she bring your pet raven or your non binaries that by Neri,
um,
Paulie by Raven.
You're at,
um,
thousand ranch,
thousand ranch.
ICOMP guys,
Tom segura.com.
Guys,
check it out.
What a great Christmas.
Could you imagine getting tickets to see your favorite comedian Tom Segora under
the tree?
I think that's a,
that's a wonder.
Especially if you're married and you guys want to do a date night,
why not come see my husband?
Oh,
there you go.
For date and I or me or whoever you like.
Joey Diaz.
Yeah.
Airy Schaffer.
Jerome and Duncan Trussell.
Dude,
I love the way you're doing this.
I love that book.
Kreischer the crusher crusher.
What was the one you said Jarell again,
you put the emphasis on the different syllable,
Rogan,
Joe Rogan and uh,
we're ready to start the show.
And don't forget if you are one of those people that are like,
wow,
that's a lot of ads.
Don't forget to bite the tip of Your Dad's Dick off and uh,
let us know what he says afterwards.
Okay?
Yep.
Feel free to let us know your feelings and go ahead and email at Bert Kreischer
or tweet at Bert Kreischer.
Yeah,
tell that Burton now your feelings about these ads and tell him,
ask him.
Well,
you know what I mean?
Get Him.
Tell him how,
how your dad responded when you bit his Dick.
Also treat Bert.
They brought I bit my dad's Dick and this is what he did.
And then he'll be like,
what the fuck is that?
We feel the ads.
I mean,
your mom's house is free.
Why don't have to listen to commercials.
Boom was really going to be a pub.
Burt,
here we go.
Hi.
Don't bring anyone.
Love it.
Well,
go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Yeah.
MMM.
That wasn't even going to be our,
our opening club.
He saw it and it was,
this kid's adorable.
So I love it.
It says,
why are you so fat bird baby?
It is like we've gotten the foreign,
we have so many additions.
Okay.
Uh,
that was submitted by Aleisha.
See Alicia,
you have an adorable,
adorable kid and we should say this.
I want to say this.
You know,
you guys,
some of you know,
so we don't burn press.
Sorry.
Bart is one of my closest friends,
closest fattest friends.
And um,
his new show time special comes out this weekend.
I'm really excited.
Site,
right?
Yeah.
So it's airing at Friday,
November 11th at 11.
At 10:00 PM he sent him yes.
It's on demand the next day.
Um,
it's,
you know,
I just,
I'm so happy for him.
He's a,
you know,
he's a great guy.
We,
he's a fattest,
funniest guy working today.
There's nobody like nobody.
Nobody's fat first shot from this special,
which he did shirtless,
but he did shortlist,
which I'm hoping not only just kind of gives a,
another jumpstart to the bird is fat movement,
but also to the bird is fat shirts are that are available right now
in our store.
Um,
but yeah,
this is a looks good.
Burger.
Oh my life.
Oh Jesus.
Credit a whole special,
like I know,
which is actually smarter for him because he sweats a lot and it's easier than
sweating through multiple shirts.
Sure.
And you know,
it doesn't distract the audit.
Like no one's gonna want to look at this.
So maybe I'll focus more on the material.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
So,
well he,
he has been going shirtless in the clubs for a while.
So this was a natural progression.
Yeah.
I think it's,
I think it's a good move.
Yeah.
The thing is though,
once that becomes his hook,
then he's going to have to do once it becomes,
or when it became you talking.
Right.
Cause now it's like doing the tonight show shirtless is that we commit to being
shirtless now.
Signed deal.
Yeah.
Can I tell you that?
We have a new bet going?
What's that?
It was established today.
Oh Great.
He was,
um,
he was all,
he was doing Ari Arie,
Arie Shaffer.
And then we're doing a podcast and I was talking to them and because I already
had texted me like,
what do you way?
And I was like,
oh,
he's going to answer.
I did.
I answered honestly.
Yeah.
I weighed myself this morning.
So,
um,
at first he texted me that Burt was two 57 and I lit up.
I was like,
what?
Because that's so much for,
especially for bird cause I have no sense of what fat is for men gets to me as a
woman that would be morbidly obese.
Like well it is two bills.
So what's normal for a boy?
It kind of depends man.
It depends like height,
six foot tall.
That's where we are.
We're both six feet.
And what should you way we should wait?
Well should way or like what would be a better way desirable.
Better wait for us would be in the two 15 to two 20 range.
That would be like a healthier one.
Do the math here.
Yeah.
And then like what would be like,
uh,
you know,
if somebody was like,
here's definitely where you should be,
they would definitely say that's true.
Then you should be.
Of course,
of course we are.
I didn't know how much fat or if we were like really healthy.
We,
but we'd weigh like one 90
but he doesn't make you 57 Oh,
I have mine on airplane mode.
I swear.
Every time that happens,
you look at me like you're going to beat,
you can't beat me up.
And I'd call the cops.
No,
it's on airplane.
Okay.
I'm sorry sweetie.
I'm sorry.
Oh God.
So like Turner,
Turner iteration.
Fuck Bitch.
So anyways,
he's two 40 he says,
no way.
It's what he said.
I weighed myself this morning,
two 42 so we're two pounds apart.
We have a kind of a bad time.
We have a bad cold.
I know.
Who knows?
But we have a back.
Okay.
January 1st,
second and third you have to weigh yourself three days in a row.
So that doesn't count.
It's a real way.
So it's not like you sweat it out and then push it out.
Yeah,
right.
Whoever is lower three days consistently.
Right?
Right.
After the new year,
we'll
win the bet.
So whoever's lower and then the loser has to take like let's burn is going to
lose.
Third has to take me and Ari to a,
an event of some kind of desirable event,
so it could be like a sporting event,
a concert.
That's fine.
Some type of show,
whatever.
Like a Rihanna,
Rihanna comes to town and Ari and I were like,
oh my God,
Omg I,
she's yellow.
Brown diamonds are in the air.
Then Brant has to take the two of us,
first of all burnt is going to take you and secondly to forties a lie.
There's no,
I don't think it was two 40 yeah,
he's way above that.
Yeah.
The other thing is
I fully recognize that Bart could write,
sly could win this thing easily because he,
he just has the body type that responds to doing this.
You know that cutting something out really well,
but he won't do it.
You mean alcohol?
Yeah.
What you need to not being an alcoholic and I have the,
I have the advantage of it being after new years.
Imagine what he does on new years.
Oh,
he's going to blow it out.
He's probably got a week's worth of shows is somewhere in the country and he's
going to be every night it's going to be like,
Ooh,
partying and then,
and then the food after right around two 30 in the morning.
Yeah,
he's foolish.
I'm looking at the calendar for what?
Yeah.
Let's see what's at the staple center.
I don't want some like top row shit.
I want like floor seats.
I'm going to make,
I'm going to make them cough it up.
Is there a football happening while we were talking about the rose bowl,
but that would be like right then and there,
but maybe,
you know,
I dunno.
Maybe it's airy.
Like football.
I think he likes it enough and it likes it enough.
Yeah,
it's a free ticket.
So this,
it's just for the hang.
Well let's think of it.
Let's plan your event now.
Cause God knows that Bart will be buying you guys tickets.
Yeah,
there's no way.
It's two 40 is there any way to verify that?
Wait,
I feel like she's lying.
I don't know.
I think,
I think airy saw him way himself or something.
So I think that one might be,
let's see,
what is the,
um,
uh,
we need an objective scale.
I know,
let's see.
What are you looking for looking for the bowl games for 2017.
Here you go.
Near you go.
You are your perfect smile.
Big Games.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Just for the championship game is and Burt's hometown in Tampa Tampon.
So does he have to fly you guys out?
I think that'd be a lot to ask,
but I think I'm going to,
the game would be really fun.
The Fun,
let's see.
It is the Roosevelt January 2nd.
So that'd be right in the middle of it.
That'd be the easiest to go to.
Yeah.
Maybe we should talk,
maybe we should get them and just see who has to make whoever has,
yeah,
that's a good idea.
You can see,
uh,
the,
the big game is in Tampa in January 9th.
So you and I have been on a similar diet.
I started seeing a personal trainer finally after 40 years of being out of shape
and she put me on what's known as the primal diet,
which sounds similar.
Is this with Joe Rogan does.
He does Kido,
which is what you do.
Yeah,
but he did.
I think he's done primal.
I think so.
What's the difference between what I'm doing and what you guys do?
Cause it sounds very similar,
I think.
Well,
mine is supposed to be high fat,
moderate protein.
Oh,
net carbs only from veggies.
All right.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's pretty simple.
I can have more carbs in you,
I believe,
and I can have dairy in moderation.
Yeah.
Uh,
but it's high fat and protein and veggies.
Yeah,
it's pretty,
I don't know.
It's pretty gnarly.
I've been shitting so much.
Yeah,
but you're good at that.
I'm so good at it.
It's like I take primal dumps and then the thought of eating like what I can eat
is not very exciting.
Yeah.
So I just,
I just don't eat as much as I used to.
And then denial,
lose weight.
So it was pretty great.
So far.
I've lost a couple pounds mostly from shitting,
but hmm.
I'm down 25 pounds.
It's amaze.
Yeah.
And how long have you been doing this for what it feels like I'm getting until
I'm hitting like around two months.
Ah,
it's great.
You look great.
I've had a couple,
you know,
you fall off the wagon a couple of times,
but basically it's there.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
I've,
I've been good without alcohol.
Even just not drinking wine I think is then the wine makes me hungrier.
Yeah.
Cause then it sugar in your belly
sugar and your belly sugar in your belly.
Um,
check this out.
I got something to play for you.
Are you ready?
We haven't done this in awhile.
It's big news.
Chips in a bowl.
Then it's chips in a bowl.
News.
Wow.
Sorry.
Just to get ready for the announcement and hold on,
wait a minute.
I found my flask.
It was missing and then,
no,
no.
Don't pretend.
Mm.
Yeah.
I'm drinking out of my,
if you haven't my personal main mommy water champ flask.
Yeah,
but he made a Christmas purchase.
They want
to get the brand new water champion tee shirt.
Um,
go to Tom segura.com.
Click on the store and it'll,
it will route you to our store.
Um,
it looks great.
Merge method is our,
our new store.
But anyways,
it's the brand new water champion shirt.
I love 'em.
I think it's really,
really,
really good.
Here's the thing,
you can rock it.
You can be the old water,
the water champion in your house.
You,
you can buy it for somebody else.
If you differ.
For instance,
like Christina does and she acknowledges it,
you could then give it to your,
um,
let me mute you real quick and then,
uh,
you could buy it.
You would have it too.
You could give it to 'em that's ready to ship to the champion in your life.
But
we'll see.
You know what I'm going to do when I get mine is I'm going to have my initials,
my monogram put on there and we're very proud of the water challenge that it
hasn't ended people.
Every time I hit the stage,
they're like,
drink up.
Fuck.
Have they ask you to drink water?
I was funny.
That's because you're not auto right already drinking.
When I pound a bottle,
they cheer like chugging beer.
Yeah.
Well you know what I do is I had a special dress custom made that con that I can
hold two water containers in an I do per custom made.
I did,
I had a tailor so in two pockets and I put a bottle water and eat.
I'm not lying or ask my audience.
It's come to see my audience and I drink both bottles while onstage.
A self help guru would ask my audience.
They are,
they are my guru.
How come this got way,
way louder.
It's did you turn me up a little bit there?
Did,
I mean Amemiya yeah,
that's better now.
Water Champ.
Sure.
It very good.
Christmas item also and genes.
We're moving next week.
Do you know that we've done nothing.
We've moved three times.
Three times.
Yeah.
Because of various um,
annoying reasons,
but now we're just sticking to it.
Now.
We're just going,
we're just fucking going.
But we've done nothing so far and we impacted nothing.
We have thrown away.
Nothing.
But number one on my priority list is ordering total wash.
Let's now what's interesting is I went into the,
I'll show you what I discovered.
I went into the total store.
They don't sell them at the toto store.
It's like a showroom.
The Guy told me that there's a newer model,
like basically we have the dinosaur of the total washlet.
Let me see if I can find it.
Here we go.
The model we need to get is a three 50 he cannot wait.
Now it's,
they said it's significantly less on Amazon.
That's what I want to do with their,
this is what I want to do to eat.
You can get it for half the price basically on Amazon.
Sounds good.
Uh,
using our banner.
Oh yeah.
We're going to buy our toto through our banner.
Of course.
I encourage you guys,
if you want to buy a total wash,
let or anything on Amazon this Christmas season,
Christmas is coming very fast.
Please use our banner,
your mom's House podcasts like,
Huh?
Well,
the banner on the homepage,
by the way,
we had,
we had a very,
very exciting conversation with one Dan Pena.
Oh my God.
So exciting.
We don't have it for you today because it was extensive and we have to basically
have it cut down so that it's appropriate to share with you.
But we'll also,
I think we should also just put up the full conversation as a separate video.
They should really hear him because he's so amazing.
But when we were on rogue and there's this whole story because we were on Rogan
and we were thinking about,
you know,
what is the,
some of the exciting things we've played on the show since the last time we saw
Joe and you know,
the one with two times before we,
we introduced them to king ass river and um,
which catapulted him into the limelight.
Yeah.
And then with Pena we brought him up but Joe wasn't sure if he was going to get
taken down because of people you know and their,
their usage rights paying.
It doesn't give a shit.
But Joe didn't know that
well cause Dan gives everything away for free.
That's his whole thing.
But we didn't,
I didn't know that.
We know.
We didn't want to assume that for Dan the $50 billion man,
that guy.
Yes.
He doesn't give a shit though.
Yeah,
that's what he's almost dead.
I don't think we can play stuff without getting sued.
Jamie.
Hello Joe.
My name is Dan Pena.
I'm still a far more for us at six one two 25 and if you think that I'm almost
dead and I'm not going to be alive anymore.
Asked his bear that I killed with a fucking knife not too long ago.
It's still a very tough fucking guy at 71 I take no bullshit in person or on the
fucking youtube.
I'm not yet and I'm funny alive and I don't give a fuck what anybody says about
me.
I rip people's head off and shit down their neck for one tough ride or another
tough guy.
Don't be afraid.
Don't be scared to use my stuff on your podcast.
It's all fucking free.
You asked me,
why do you give it away free,
Dan?
I give it away for you to take the last fucking excuse boy from the,
sorry,
because why they can't fulfill their dream.
I'm calling you out,
Joe.
You think you're a tough guy.
You haven't met me on the $50 billion man.
And this is my lair.
Yeah.
Guy's the fucking best guy,
man.
Look at Penney's castle,
I know.
Isn't that nuts?
Yeah.
Mother fucker lives there and is layer that shit.
You know,
then I'll fucking be all shit.
Right.
You're fucking suit.
What are you wearing your fucking jeans?
I can't.
I was so excited.
We had a great conversation today.
We spoke to Dan pain yet cause he's,
he's gracious enough to accommodate because he's in England.
So we had to go back and forth for a couple of weeks here.
Took a minute to,
to find the time that worked for both of us and he's also,
he just finished up doing another Qla seminar and his castle and jeans.
I was,
I don't think I've ever been that,
that excited to talk like we've spoken with Gloria.
Stefan,
no brace from Gigolos.
I love our list.
It's amazing joy.
I remember Jules Ventura tour has been in the studio and I was of major get for
us.
I mean I was sweating with excitement to talk to him was,
he was great too.
He was great.
He's a fantastic speaker and an end,
a great guest.
And I can't wait for you guys to hear the interview we had with them.
So hopefully we'll get it in order.
Yeah,
we just have to take,
you know,
will it cause yeah,
it'd be like we've done that before by the way.
Where you like you just play some the whole thing yet.
But we will put it up for what they want to hear,
the whole thing.
I read people's head off and shit down their neck.
Yeah,
I love it.
Really talks like that too.
And he does casual conversation.
He does.
Um,
so I was involved meet this weekend where Raul Rob Ball meet Rob North Carolina.
And which club is that?
The comedies.
Charlie goodnight's.
Yeah.
I went there and you know what,
I didn't realize,
you know,
a big seam in whole fan.
Yeah.
Florida state.
Thursday was playing there.
I couldn't go to the game.
I was six at the same time as my shows,
but um,
I got to meet up with,
you know,
I'm such a big fan and I've been Twitter friends with some of the columnists and
writers,
you know,
cover them.
So I met up with one after the show.
It's really fun.
That's exciting.
So you,
it's like a pen pal.
It is just like a pen pal that I met.
Yeah.
And did you guys jerk off in each other's mouths?
The halls?
Yup.
That's exactly what we did together.
And take your dogs out and go,
hey,
that's pretty good.
Yeah,
that's a really neat story.
How'd you can tell our son your version of the story one day?
Oh,
this is border.
Not even borderline.
You just basically,
yeah.
Ooh,
okay.
I'm done with you now.
Thank you.
Those are big words.
That's the way you did that.
It was very big word of you
making fun of the song you're making.
To me it felt like you were making fun of native Americans.
So I didn't like it made me uncomfortable.
Big words that was not racist.
And Lola blamed the semen holes for Marcelo profanity.
I felt like it.
Why don't you blame the semen holes for having a racist mascot and sought a
racist mascot?
Absolutely.
First of all,
the Seminole nation supports the,
uh,
the university using Seminoles as a,
the spot on the team,
right?
Absolutely.
So then how has my paying homage to their music?
It was disrespectful the way you did it.
It was disrespectful.
Ooh.
Ooh,
God.
And then you do the Tomahawk Chop.
I know all this cause I've been watching you do it for 50 years.
Yeah.
50 years now.
Before your flight.
Yeah.
Did you go there?
This is my song.
Did you guys
see they're saying how you did it?
Come on boy.
Yeah,
school.
It's cool.
I do like that.
We're stopping the yard.
What's that playing there?
That's my Tallahassee date.
Oh,
okay.
I'm doing the school.
Oh,
that's fun.
That,
yeah,
where he goes,
what are they doing?
They're stopping the car.
Remember that?
I think that stomp the yard,
but don't you quote that a lot?
Yeah.
He's so dumb.
We'll say it.
Say it the way he's stopping the young man boobs.
That's what he,
he,
I think he,
man,
they stomp in the yard.
So does Chris Brown.
Right?
And that he beat the shit out of.
Oh,
Rihanna.
I forgot about that.
Yeah.
What's going on with it when this company?
Yeah,
I think that man,
they stop and that means just to dance right there dancing.
Like you're still doing it.
Like they're dying.
They're going bird.
It's cold in here.
Yeah.
There must be some clovers in that.
Uh,
most fear.
I'll said birds coding,
I just to bring it on.
So that's why it's in my mind is cold in here then I must,
oh,
that's a great movie.
Ooh,
got serious.
So we got in a fight,
they got hurt.
Somebody stumped
space.
And I like supposed to be this
real serious,
sit down here at act like I want to be here.
You're the only thing your mom has got nothing.
Oh dear.
Hell of a door open.
He gone.
Well,
we got lucky.
That's in the trailer.
Ice Cream.
Elevate dorm.
Elevate door was still open.
He got
tell,
he says like,
you dumb bitch.
You don't know what that stuff's called stupid to hell.
Or they just stop in the yard,
man.
Yeah,
I wouldn't know what that's called.
Of course they're doing their dance routines.
They're working on their raps.
Yeah,
they're wrapping up.
Yeah.
Gosh,
guys are dancing and into your mom was great.
Anthony.
Same with content.
Then we'll come right.
The hell of they doing?
Where are you from?
Right?
Where are you from,
dummy.
You idiot people don't stomp the yard in the cafeteria where you're from.
That's the first time I ever saw that freshman here.
You don't even know this thought.
The yard.
Well,
part of the world.
Are they like in the south somewhere?
I Dunno where that's,
it looks like a an Hbcu,
but I don't know where it is.
Hmm.
Just stop in the yard,
dummy.
Don't you know that
Ali woke up?
Lj?
Maybe.
Probably from staff in the arts allows,
dumped the,
yeah.
Yeah.
Uh,
what was the point of this discussion?
Oh,
I was going to say,
so you left really early for your flight.
You're like,
uh,
an 11:00 AM fly,
but you loved the house lake six in the morning.
And I was like,
are you going to the Strip club before you get on your flight?
And then I texted you that that's where I was.
I left so early just cause there was a strip club by lax.
Good plastic Ziploc bag.
I wouldn't say she has eaten some Ziploc bag.
God,
what a dummy.
How are you alive?
She's definitely not stomping the yard.
So
could you imagine the people do that?
Of course they do that.
That's why.
Sure.
Clubs look,
they're everywhere and people go at all different times for different reasons,
which I understand.
I don't,
I don't think going to strip clubs is weird.
But you brought to my attention this specific location and stories about it that
were very amusing,
I think.
Well we started joking around the house now that every time you go to the
airport,
wow.
That was loud.
Yeah.
Imagine if we had the Fart Mike.
I know it would have been a lot better.
I know,
but,
uh,
my father had his best friend who's now dead,
but they would,
they went to Costa Rica trip once and they want extra early to the airport so
that my dad's friend could go to the Strip club.
So his wife dropped him off at the airport and I'm like,
see you later sweetie.
And then they got into a cab and went to the Nudey bar.
Yeah.
And then go back to you go back to the airport,
get on the flight.
So he's getting ramped up for the trip.
That's all.
I mean,
it makes sense.
I don't think it's that weird.
I just think it's funny that,
that you know someone so closely.
Yeah.
It's funny.
It's silly.
It's silly that you like your wife drops you off and then you leave the airport
titty bar because that was the flight.
And then what I would have to do to go is I would have to do with like four
hours early.
That's the part that's funny is that you're going to like,
oh my God,
I'm gonna get up at 4:00 AM
10:00 AM flight and like why not just land at the destination and then find a
nudey bar?
Like you have to go before the flight in the morning.
You got to really love it or you can just need breakfast.
That's something I didn't know about until I was much older was that there's a
big strip clubs that serve food and that some people are like,
hey,
the food is really good.
Yeah,
it can't be really good,
but it's buffet,
right?
Like it's crappy.
I've never had it.
Um,
I did have steak.
There's,
there's one,
like in Florida,
there's a chain of a steakhouse that's also a topless bar,
but it's known to be a good steakhouse.
I'd look it up and then I had to set there plus steakhouse or maybe it's,
you know,
it's like,
let me see.
I think you're saying stick.
Let people go.
People are like,
this is like,
it is good steak topless.
It's like Hooters house where you're like,
no,
no.
I'm going to Hooters for the chicken wings.
Is it Rachel steakhouse?
Yes.
She's chewing.
That's supposed to be good.
I mean,
and I remember I went there years and years ago.
Where is that?
What part of Florida?
Uh,
it looks like there's one in Tampa and uh,
let's see.
Orlando.
Yeah,
it seemed like some of the big cities.
Now Betsy is chewing on.
It's memorable.
It's not like I go,
no,
it wasn't like I go,
man,
that's the best steak of my life.
But it's like,
it's good.
It's good for a titty bar,
I imagine.
Right.
But what I wouldn't do,
and what I've heard of people doing is breakfast.
It's like scrambled eggs,
buffet at the Strip club.
I'm not into that,
especially by the airport.
Like I understand if you're in Vegas and you just,
you know,
you just blew it out all night and you're hung over and just go the,
it's funny.
It's fun.
Sure.
But just for a flight,
like for a flight,
get commitment.
It seems like you really want it.
You really need it.
You really need it
to be,
we got to make a pit stop.
You really need to come in your payments.
The thing is like you also are for a flight.
Any inconvenience is magnified.
You really inconveniencing yourself already shitty to wake up and go to the
fucking airport.
You go through security,
you want extra early
leaving the airport,
getting into a cats,
a lot,
getting hammered and then coming back.
Yeah.
It just seems like a lot for a more,
but I guess it makes,
you know,
it makes,
I understand it more that they went on.
They did it before there.
There Bro.
Trip Bro Down 50th Birthday.
Yeah,
but maybe you don't know,
but it sounds like that dude from what I've heard about him,
he might have done that on any flight.
His routine.
Yeah.
I don't think it's because this was the special birthday tram me ask you this.
If you ever drop your daughter off at the airport.
I'm trying to,
yeah,
come to think of it.
I drop him off like six hours early all the time.
It's interesting here.
I hate being late.
I hate,
sure.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
It's so funny when you realize your parents are like,
you know people,
they are,
wait a minute.
And it's funny because my dad be like,
yeah,
my best friends and all this stuff.
That's always a good one,
not me.
I don't know if you're the best friend
probably in the same stuff.
They're into one thing.
We know a guy,
but when is your best friend and you're like,
yeah,
we always hang out,
but he only,
he does stuff.
Yeah.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's pretty funny.
Oh yeah.
He does a good friend though.
Nobody has a good friend.
My Dad is a good friend.
Yeah.
A friend.
Yeah,
for sure.
of course.
It seems like a,
is it bro?
He keeps it to fucking sell 100 dude.
Yeah,
go to the Strip club.
Um,
this guy reminded me,
a lot of you,
so I wanted to bring this clip up,
see if this reminds you of yourself.
Okay.
What else?
Baby Jane Love.
You know what I'm saying?
You know what it is the street fucking legend.
Yoed but now rocking was Stackhouse is smack and it stacking get him chips.
Getting that paper be yeah.
Whoa.
Big words.
No.
If you uh,
don't know yet,
that's a white guy that we're listening to.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't do it.
It sounds like you,
I think a lot of people will be like,
oh my God,
I thought that was Christina.
This dude is apparently a big producer in the mix tape game.
[inaudible] he put out one of nozzles,
mix tapes and he put out,
uh,
he worked on a ghost face killer.
Kool g rap mix tape.
Hmm.
Let me see.
Just so as JL,
yeah,
Jay love.
Okay.
So that's his name.
Um,
but apparently he really,
he's real comfortable with the big words.
Sounds like it.
Especially for,
okay.
Got It.
Ease Dj Niggas.
You know what I'm saying?
They're like bandwagon,
you know what I'm saying?
Like let's say one niggers want shop play one following,
He's just scared to take chances.
Scared to play records.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like everybody got an always,
you know,
follow and I ain't even know that ain't me,
man.
I,
I've never been there and I'm a grown man.
You know what I'm saying?
My notes Hang,
you know?
Yeah.
White niggers.
Yeah,
yeah.
Geez.
Who's saying the big words now Tom?
No,
you hit the button.
Everybody takes something.
You can just store seem to be the street in,
you know,
we supposed some respect you as a mixed tape Nigga.
She is Madison.
It's not easy to say overnight success.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I hate,
he's also really good to know sayings.
It's kind of doing both.
He's doing that.
Yeah.
And you know what's neat too about this video is the beard,
the poor lighting,
the beard center for the Audio.
The audio
throughout Jesus eating his homeboy would have just flicked on any light.
Yeah.
Jay Love Man.
Jay Love.
So Dj is Debbie Quinn.
Like cds were like baby songs or 15 seconds put out a CD every three days just
like,
Yo,
you're cold bull son.
You know what I'm saying?
But that's because nick has only sell 203 on it.
So please,
please,
please take it for free.
You know,
can I,
and I'm wondering the sincerely,
like what point as a white person,
it sounds like there's a black guy in the room with him if I'm not mistaken.
It does sound like that.
Yeah.
Like how does that happen where you're given the past?
I think it's a good question.
I think the answer is over time.
This dude is so deep in hip hop and specifically with,
seems like with New York guys,
which means that he's hanging out with like real street dudes and he probably,
you know what it probably is what I think it is.
If you're a New York guy like him,
you're hanging out.
Yeah.
With a lot of black guys.
But then you hang out with a lot of light Puerto Rican guys who are like,
some of them technically not black and they talk like this.
So then you're like,
that's not a black guy.
He talks like this.
He gets away with it.
Then if you have success with,
um,
you know,
he's worked on a nas mix tape.
It looks like he's worked on a rock Kim mix tape.
He's worked on mob deep Dmx,
Lord Finesse Craig g Masta Ace,
like all these guys.
And if they're talking to him like that and they start,
you know,
making him feel like that's,
okay,
whatever they get there.
That's what I think it's just,
it's just over,
over time that first time,
like where he drops it,
you know?
And it's a risk.
Yeah.
Okay.
I guess I can keep going.
He's probably said to him,
it's spoken so heavily around him.
It's like becoming fluent in a language,
you know,
fits your culture and yeah.
But yeah,
I guess you're just,
you're in the culture now is interesting.
And it is,
I think it like,
yeah,
when you're like really,
um,
you know,
when you're learning language,
really learning it,
you go to that country and you live there and after a while it starts to come
out of you naturally.
Right.
So he's hanging out with brothers.
This is like an in studio street talk exactly like this.
Like he's actually sounding exactly cadence wise.
Like,
like a hip Hop New York black dude
told bull son calling on me.
Yeah.
That's how,
like that's like a,
how a guy who's probably at this point 40 or older talks about like you,
I mean like a Dj who's 45 would be like,
Yo,
you will call them both.
So he just picked up on all that.
It's what's what he was all he knows is what he's surrounded.
Just I wish I could see black people's faces when he,
you know what I mean?
Like they could send us pictures of it as they were like,
you guys want to go ahead and send us a picture of your face as you're heard
this or is like,
there's probably people right now who are like,
there's no way this guy's white and he's super white too.
Irish pasty.
Yeah,
he's white.
Yeah.
He's,
we had this conversation when I did,
um,
I did Jim and Sam.
I did them this week when they were in la,
but two weeks ago in New York and um,
Jim was out,
but Sam was,
was hosting,
we had the,
a,
a little bit of the n word because there was a Fox News contributor,
uh,
who,
who's black in studio and about like white people being able to use it.
Oh,
her position,
her position was like,
and no negative,
negative.
Negative.
Yeah.
Well maybe you know,
my position was if you're in your car alone,
how bad it,
I've always thought that the song thing is absurd.
Like to be like you can't say it when you're singing a song.
You can say it if you're saying in the song,
but use common sense.
Right?
Like it's in a song,
I'm sorry a white person can't say it if it's like,
well give that Jay z song,
but I'm saying is in Paris when you request.
Right.
But my point is that you're an asshole and you know what you're doing.
If you're saying it out loud and like looking at a black guy,
like don't be stupid.
That's obviously like that's,
you know,
that to me is just common sense,
right?
You gotta be selective when you're saying then where does what you're saying?
Well,
I'm saying like,
you know,
it's in a song so you have,
you can repeat a song like no one's gonna tell you.
Right,
right.
But like is there is also just stupidity,
like,
yeah.
If you're trying to do it to,
to test whether or not you're going to get in trouble,
that's dumb.
That's dumb.
Yeah.
You can,
you sing your song really driving in your car,
obviously you're going to sing it then.
You know what I mean?
Like you're not going to get a sense of yourself in the car.
Yeah.
Like it's silly to,
yeah.
Anyways,
it's declining.
It's Dick Rod and all the cross man swag.
Whoever's the hardest thing to get to China.
Wow.
But it flowers same biggie.
You know what I'm saying?
They use it.
It'll Nigga,
because you started that commercial shit.
Shit.
This dude really is deep in his,
yeah,
it's his,
it's his world.
But this is like a,
like a Truman show experiment.
There's something,
you know,
like he's really deep.
Deep in.
Yeah.
It's like becoming a,
a hip hop DJ,
but also 100% of the way of black.
They would do it.
Yeah.
She's sharing that.
We gotta get,
we gotta get her out of there then.
Hey.
Hey schnitzel dude.
She's getting,
she's going to eat that.
I know.
Come on man.
I don't know.
I don't want to kick her out
cause then they're just going to bark.
We got to get that out of her,
out of her hands,
Babe.
Okay.
Schnitzel.
Oh my God was she just kind of picks on all stuff on the ground,
you know?
Okay.
I can't.
It's just like a nut.
It's just a constant thing with her.
Maybe I should just create them.
I Dunno.
She did so come.
You're dumb dumb.
Yeah.
This is not good.
[inaudible] come here.
Come here,
baby Bissell.
Just gonna hold her.
Yeah.
For now until she calms down.
Can you pick that stuff up?
I can't.
I can't reach it until I have to take off everything.
Okay.
She just going to go get it.
There's a million other thing on the floor,
like an analyst thing.
Okay.
Here is the uh,
super.
Yeah,
Jay love,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what it is one love Nigga.
You know what I'm saying with,
you know what I'm saying?
It was Dj Niggas,
They're like band wagon Niggas,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm saying I think he's just scared to take chances,
I'm the same way.
You don't see,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
Do you know what I'm saying?
But do you know what I'm saying?
You got Niggas that was so cds for like 75 cents.
You know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying with no,
he's,
you know what I'm saying?
So,
you know,
I don't know man.
That shit,
man.
You know what I'm saying,
Jay?
You know what I'm saying?
The Dj Niggas,
you know what I'm saying?
Niggas ain't trying to be both the lab and in the streets,
You just said,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
They can know what I'm saying.
It's like,
you know what I'm saying is the weapons that I say,
you know what I'm saying?
Everybody follows
his big words.
Distracted from how many know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
I feel like it just came into,
I just came to go like we should really be talking about is,
you know what I'm saying is right,
but it's big words were always separate.
The big word founding from the have to super cuts.
Well,
I don't know if I want to hear the n word.
Okay.
Say Love.
You know what I'm saying?
This is a,
you know
what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
You don't know what I'm saying.
Do you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying with no,
he's,
you know what I'm saying?
You know what I'm saying?
I don't know man.
I liked the pizza.
You know what I'm saying?
Then when I don't know.
I don't know.
Why doesn't my fucking caffeine thing work?
I don't know Booboo,
why I fucking downloaded it.
I've activated it.
Why the fuck doesn't it work?
I don't know.
Anti blue.
Bam.
Look at it.
God dammit,
mother fucker.
His facial hair was horrendous.
Yeah,
it was bad.
It was really bad.
God,
that was more distracting than the the [inaudible].
That's terrible.
Look good.
Look.
That is not good for him.
Especially when you've got two chins.
You gotta be real careful.
Yeah,
you do.
But you know he's doing his thing.
You know what I'm saying?
It's,
you know what I'm saying?
It's all about the,
the cut of the beer.
Yeah.
You know,
like that you have a thicker beard,
a thicker beard.
Like I'm below deck that the captain who shaves it like it's right here,
bro,
on the Jawline,
right on the jawline and you can't do that.
You got to build yourself a job.
Like how you do it is great.
Burt's got a great beard too.
You got to do it that way.
Yeah.
If you're a big guy,
he's an even live here or not.
I just think that beard cut is a horrendous to do it right on the,
uh,
the chin.
No Good God dammit.
Speaking of interesting looks crazy lugs has a trailer out.
Oh my God.
We haven't talked about him in a long time.
Um,
doing his thing and stuff like that.
I think it's,
they said trays called crazy looks the movie.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Let's see.
You want to see it?
I'm very interested in my,
this is Chris and motherfucker know motherfucker.
Joe Something.
Yes.
Something young stars.
No.
Nope.
Filled with haters.
Haters.
Gimme
a break and stuff like that.
Stuff like that.
Most men would crumble.
Interesting.
Christ loves going on.
Pushed to his limits.
Broken.
Yeah.
I know what this for
as the show.
Pretty serious.
Yes.
To
punching a concrete
guy.
Punches Times this guy,
this guy punches the man.
Wow.
Them out.
He's looking good.
The myth looking good.
Oh my God.
This guy shit so many.
Yeah,
you're not.
You're definitely right about that.
Oh,
Shit.
Crazy.
There he is.
That's my favorite.
That's how it all started in the supermarket.
Yeah.
Whoa.
My goodness.
Let it kick.
He punches.
Yeah.
It's got a Tan Line of a wife beater.
I see.
Everybody wears them.
Yeah.
So most known keep eight by pushing.
All right.
Um,
I'm hitting San Jose next year.
I hope I get to meet the loads.
I hope so too.
Matter of fact,
I'll make a public announcement now.
I'd like to meet crazy looks at my San Jose show.
Are you sure you ready now?
I think I'm ready,
but I think I started training.
I know I'll keep pushing,
you know,
if I win that Burt bet,
I'll be that much better at this.
So get ready Kate [inaudible] am a trainee.
Try to rapping.
He looks good.
He does crazy.
Looks.
Looks good.
It looks crazy.
You got a whole thing man?
Yeah,
he looks good though.
Speaking of a good looks,
we have another submission for a horrible,
hilarious.
Okay.
Um,
so we're either going to laugh or be really,
really horrified.
Ready?
Here we go.
Hmm.
I don't like these down.
Yes.
I want to go home and smoke a fucking huge fucking,
oh fuck dude.
Oh my God.
I hit the shit out of a fucking bear.
Are you here?
Oh my God.
That's not cool.
No,
I got to get off the phone.
I'll talk to you soon.
Um,
hilarious.
Is that what you're thinking?
No,
it was like,
it looked like it was a bummer.
I don't know who was laugh at that one.
Hitting an innocent bear.
I think that's the point.
Jesus man,
and it was a bummer.
I hope that the bear seemed to be okay.
They like walk
did off.
Yeah,
he did.
God,
I was terrible.
Imagine how resilient they are,
how big they are,
I think weighs how much as much as the car at least I don't know about that,
but that's a big fucker and he went rolling and then got up and just walk in the
woods.
I was terrible.
All right.
Well definitely horrible.
Thanks.
Thank you for sending that in and horrifying us.
That really,
God,
I don't want to see that shift to take care of the Schnitz.
She's chilling again.
Vamp for a minute.
You want to just talk?
Okay.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Come on guys.
Fucking Schnitz.
Oh my God,
that was so,
so bad.
Please never send me an animal getting a hit by a car hit send me people getting
hit by a car.
That's the shit I find funny.
Um,
and not hit,
you know what I mean?
I don't want to see someone killed just something with a funny reaction.
He didn't see a reaction when an animal gets hit.
It's just sad.
God dammit.
All right.
Um,
I've been to the Ali Museum.
What am I going to do and fucking Lewisville.
I gotta find something to do on a Saturday.
Yeah.
Any Friday.
Oh good.
You talk about what happened about yeah.
No,
you want to tell him shit,
go ahead.
So
last night you came home from the road and I made some vegetables,
Sunday dinner and some chicken.
I was standing,
I let the dogs out.
Yeah.
And I burped and farted at the same time and I go,
oh my God,
who am I?
God had double pipe.
Classic.
Yeah.
And you went,
I only heard the burp.
The you,
you didn't even acknowledge my hard work.
Yeah.
It's kind of upsetting when someone doesn't hear it,
but that's my second double pipe.
Classic.
This year,
5:01 PM last night.
I didn't hear the Fart and that's why I didn't say much.
No,
I didn't panties late.
Um,
but what's interesting is that I forced the burp out,
but I didn't know the Fart was coming.
Well,
that's usually how it happens.
It doesn't really happen organically is what you're saying.
Like usually you're pushing one,
right.
Other ones the surprise.
You're right.
Yeah.
Oh my God,
you're right.
Because you're pushing
cause like it,
it'll be like you,
let's say you lean up to Fart,
but there happens to be a gas bubble you don't recognize in your chest.
Right.
So you got foreign,
but Barb comes out,
you're so right.
The push of burp out fart sneaks out.
Either way.
It's awesome.
I mean,
it goes great.
Do you realize what a revelation that is,
what you just said,
like you figured out the essence of the double pipe.
Yeah.
And you're really,
what you're doing is helping people listening.
Yeah.
You're helping them get theirs.
Because we didn't really,
we didn't really put that together that
you kind of are pushing and that's why that happened.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
What a neat revelation.
Oh yeah.
Wow,
that's pretty cool.
And we're celebrating something major tomorrow.
Yeah.
Big Time.
We're going to go away for the one for one night.
Stay at a hotel that we stayed at how many years ago
we stayed at this hotel.
Um,
I wanna say somewhere between 10 and 12 years ago.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah.
And we were just dating.
Cause it's our Banis Murphy.
Yeah.
So better,
smarter for knee.
And also we're going to the hotel that is the baddest Murphy,
any of our first raw dog.
Right.
You,
and it's funny because you bring that up.
I talked about it on stage this weekend about,
I asked the guy,
the couple in the front row,
I was like,
do you remember the first time she told you you don't have to wear a condom?
And he goes,
yes.
I go see it's,
it's burned into our memory is like a,
yeah,
like a significant date.
And the animals.
Yeah,
like a,
but it's like an important,
and it is,
it's like for a guy,
I mean there's some,
obviously everyone's been with some sketchy chicks who are like,
go ahead.
Right.
Just you know,
but like I'm saying,
when your girl you're dating,
you're covered up and she's like,
you don't need that anymore.
That's like,
Whoa,
that's it's,
it's a mark of intimacy course because it means I trust that you're not banging
around right.
That you're the only one that's gonna the GOC [inaudible] in around this area.
That's a big deal.
It is a big deal.
It means your exclusive when you take that rubber off and we haven't put a
rubber on since.
No,
no,
not really.
Mostly not.
I'm really excited.
Our band a smurf knee
are mass,
but most importantly,
the raw dog,
the first,
the most important,
and we're going to tell our son about it.
I remember,
I remember you remember the first thing when we,
I was like,
well,
if we go there,
that's the raw dog place.
Oh,
you knew that that was going to happen.
No,
no.
I'm saying that's what I remember about that place too.
Saying like,
you don't have to wear that.
And I was like,
I remember also if you're a guy,
just enough girl ever says like,
you don't need to wear one.
Right.
Don't say anything,
just shut up again.
Except the gift.
That's exactly what I was getting was like,
but you know what I remember from that first.
That was our first getaway.
Yeah.
And we went away for like two nights,
two nights.
You're that you were good.
Just plowed so hard.
And I didn't make a brown for too old because we weren't shit in front of each
other yet.
We hadn't started that.
And I had to hold it and Brown for two fucking days because I didn't go to the
lobby and make it.
So what happened was,
is I eventually was like,
oh,
I'm going to go for a walk.
And then I,
but then I was afraid of being away for too long and that you pick up on it that
I was browning.
I tried going at a restaurant we went to like,
yeah,
well I couldn't shit cause here's why that the hotel room was set up such that
whatever's happening in the bathroom,
the other person can hear it smell.
It wasn't,
it's not like a closed door.
It was like the um,
I wonder if you'll offer the same level of
courtesy on this trip.
Yeah.
Doors are
going to go see if the news right.
No Dude,
but I tried to,
shit,
we went out for dinner.
I'd like this Mediterranean restaurant and I'll never forget that I tried to
shit during dinner during dinner,
but I was so nervous and backed up that I didn't Brown.
I wonder,
uh,
by the way,
I have audio of that,
that hotel when we were there 10 years ago,
[inaudible]
kind of wish you would've said something.
I didn't know I was being a nice present and bring it up all these years later.
How long have we been together total?
I always forget blood block it out a little.
I Dunno.
No serious altogether.
It's probably oh five we started right,
so almost 12 years.
So crazy.
But we've been married for,
this will be our eighth wow.
Yup.
All those farts.
Can you imagine our eighth anniversary?
I count your tits in the morning.
I count your farts.
You've got dog tits shut up like you nurse puppies and then they grew to you.
You have tests where it looks like you have a couple of pairs of Ted's tied
together.
And then if you,
if you pull them apart,
there'd be tits inside of them.
You know what?
We used to play this game before I had Ellis where we'd squeeze each other's
bellies.
Yeah,
but we do,
it's not fair anymore because I grew a person in mind and minds extra stretched
out and my tits are extra loose and low now.
It's not fair.
You can't grab my stomach meet anymore.
I sure can.
It's not fair.
Well,
it's life.
You have an unfair advantage because I made her son,
here's you from last.
Oh,
I like it when he goes.
Oh No,
I think he's winded from the far.
Oh Damn.
I like that one too.
It's good.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
So that's neat.
We're going to check into the hotel tomorrow.
We're staying for one night.
Yeah.
And we're going to raw dog it again,
dog.
Yeah.
If we don't pass out by 8:00 PM cause we're so tired,
I know it's probably going to happen.
Right.
We're going to be like,
well I haven't had alcohol now and two weeks.
I'm really excited to have a glass of wine.
Yeah.
And I'll probably eat a lot of proof judo and cheese and pickles and I'll
probably be asleep by eight o'clock.
Hmm.
For sure.
So you better get it in.
Right.
And we check in if you know what I'm saying.
Oh yeah.
Oh my gosh.
So dammit.
And what's wrong?
Jeans.
I wanted to play something.
Genes.
Genes are Ronin jeans,
jeans are moaning and get everybody that um,
submitted,
uh,
what's it called for the master?
What is it that you submit?
Patriot.
Put that shit down.
Yeah.
Uh,
that was a really fun episode we just recorded at Patriot and put that down.
That was cool man.
Put that shit down.
Just looking at my notes because I had something written down then I forgot.
That was really fun.
So make sure you check it out.
Um,
here we go.
Oh,
what did you guys need to play?
Um,
yeah,
but you go ahead.
Go ahead.
No,
we can play your shit.
Play Shit.
Uh,
here's the thing I wanted to play.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Tom Said,
master of vaccines.
Um hmm.
Well,
the reason I wanted to play for you is we have such an amazing accent and I
don't know where this person is from.
I don't know if he could maybe help me
try to guess their nationality.
Are you ready?
Here we go.
[inaudible] hours.
Lindsay Lohan.
What the fuck is going on with her?
It's exactly that.
What you should be saying.
What in the fuck is going on and what should we do you know who used to do
something like this?
A version of this,
Donna?
Yes,
but I'm talking about not as well known top dog.
When I would have so many Peruvian relatives stay,
he would start to talk to them in English,
the way they spoke English because he thinks that they would understand that.
Like he would go
when Neato so today you saw the zoo,
it was nice and we're the people,
they're nice to you.
Can I be like,
why are you talking to him?
The way he speaks English and they won't help,
you know,
he would talk to them like that.
Yeah.
So I think what happened is that she's been hanging out with these great people.
Obviously it sounds to me like an Irish Guatemalan and Irish Guatemala,
a hybrid between Guatemalan and Irish.
The Irish thing there.
But then it sounded to me,
the more I listened to it,
it sounded to me like it was,
uh,
maybe a lot of time with the Greeks and that the Greeks who speak English have
that application.
I'm trying to think of what the Greek accent,
because I've been there with sound like Latin,
but I'm saying like it's her diffused version of that weird.
So weird.
So people are scared of
[inaudible].
Yes,
she,
it sounds Irish kind of,
but then purpose I think.
But she also is speaking in broken English,
which is like if,
if she hung out with,
let's say,
like she's hanging out with some,
at some exotic like high society Greek lady who doesn't speak around 100%
English is like,
I hung out and you know,
with my,
uh,
I will say
there's something important that people don't recognize that we're on a good
nightlife.
I cannot find tonight.
But tomorrow when you,
if you go
between Germany,
all of the UN nations,
the five,
the Bible Bibles,
English is bigger than weird.
She's speaking with like,
she doesn't really speak fucking English.
It's like the foreign accent syndrome people.
They would also lose the ability to speak grammatically correct English.
This is so bizarre.
She's gotta be hanging out with some old Greek millionaire.
Yes.
Or whatever.
I think so.
Doesn't speed grease.
Welcome so many refugees from Syria.
She's fucking weird,
man.
She is a member.
When Madonna did that,
when she was,
when she first moved to England and she was really bad.
It wasn't sufferable and moving to England and we'd leg it looks like,
you know,
like shut up.
You're from Michigan,
like Michigan.
She's not from fucking London town arb,
five lads.
This is a Madonna evolution of her accident.
Oh,
for your the witch's hat.
Where's my stuff?
Say it's not as dramatic as I remember it being.
She was a little,
she was worse.
Yeah.
Why works?
I don't think these clips are that.
I don't think they're indicative of how far she went into being English.
Yeah.
Um,
but I totally think you can pick that up.
Like,
you know,
when I lived in England,
when I came back,
I picked up some stuff just because if all you're hearing is that stuff.
Yeah.
And then you come back and you're like,
speaking of accents,
you remember this from last week,
right?
We got out,
he was the gas we bought.
And look at the truck at the moment.
This is why
we've been slapping marriage battle.
Who's my Hong Kong fucking along here?
Just glass and glass all of a sudden,
clearly I didn't even know.
I didn't even put my head on.
I'm like,
God,
we're just glassing these big huge bedrooms.
Love Him.
Um,
glass.
Just glad.
Awesome Bro.
We're just glass.
Just glue.
We were out there,
glass and the murder.
He's so good.
Doug.
I just,
I just want to be excited about anything in my life as it goes,
as this guy,
right?
Yeah.
Wouldn't you just give anything to be this excited?
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That any at his age as an adult.
It's pretty cool.
Or the glass.
And um,
so there was this thing said last week.
I'm just glad you,
you were,
I said he was Canadian.
Oh fuck off.
What is he?
He's from Colorado.
It's the same.
It's very similar.
Been slumping along here.
Glass,
glass and glass.
And we're just glad.
Glad.
Well,
it's glass on glass door.
I'm like,
no,
just glass.
And how surprised that you said,
I would say,
wow,
how do we know that?
Wait a minute.
How do you know he's from Denver?
Because they found who he was.
His name is like Todd.
Okay.
He's known.
He's known a hundred guys.
So some of the listeners found him.
Maybe he spent time in Canadia Madonna or anything.
The Canadian about his accident though.
Sounds sounds good to me guys.
Look,
I know you're the master,
but I'm the mistress of accents and I,
I hear Canadian.
Well,
this person says,
dear Mommy P and water champ.
Towson.
I was stunned when Molly's,
he had the audacity to disagree with the main mommy slash master of accents.
Tommy,
I lived north of the wall in Canada for two years and have a Canadian baby
jeans,
the adjust glass and guys clearly not Canadian.
His vows aren't nearly far back enough in his mouth.
He sounds exactly like Joe Rogan's friend Cameron Hanes who was from Oregon.
It turns out this guy from Colorado.
Okay.
Anyways,
love you both.
Thank you Josh.
Just glisten guys.
Great.
Um,
anyways,
um,
I think you guys are wrong and I'm,
I'm looking forward to finding out that that guy's from Canadian.
He's not from Canadian as a Windsor native,
a proud as amazing.
You should know more.
I was born in Windsor,
Ontario and then I moved to La when I was four guys because people have been
like,
oh,
you're from the valley or are you from kin?
What was boring winter so you guys can suck on those nuts.
Okay.
Proud Windsor Native Ontario Cross from de Trois.
It's been a while since you've been home though,
right?
Classy as a guest.
Yeah.
I've,
I've only,
I've never even seen it since we left.
I don't know it.
You don't know Windsor at all?
You should go.
I should go.
Yeah,
let's go.
Let's make a trip.
A pilgrimage
Ontario trip.
Uh,
yeah.
My Dad showed me a picture of the apartment complex we lived in.
It looks real nice.
Well,
my poor immigrant parents escape from communist Hungary with like $10.
Windsor took them in the loving arms of Canada,
which is really nice.
How rough was the complex?
It didn't look like fancy,
sad,
faster when the answer's no.
It was a hard knocks.
Hard.
Cox.
Um,
but look how far we've come.
Moved on up,
man.
Like the Jeffersons.
Yeah,
man.
Thanks to Canadia.
Thank you to Canada Canadian.
Taking my family and dude,
hold on.
Did you hear it?
No.
Oh,
I had to pee at the same time.
You're about to Shit,
Huh?
What does it mean you better get your life?
I don't know what this,
I have no idea.
When you do your show and somebody who's just like really out of pocket.
Okay.
Nobody believes this story.
We'll cow's milk cause
this is not the business.
I love it.
She said out of pocket.
That's a new one to somebody out of pocket.
It sounds like.
I've never heard that.
I have for about 25 years.
You're kidding.
No.
Where have I been in white America cries square I think.
I think it's funny that she was trying to explain this square,
get your life and then she was with someone was out of pocket.
I've had a few guests that were out of pocket.
That's how I would've reacted though.
Of course.
You know what I'm saying?
You,
I'm such a bull
shit.
Like 80 tracks,
10 seconds.
He's the only move like two,
we do have a gift for you.
Oh,
is pregnant again.
Wow.
I thought she was adamant that she was never going to do that again because you
got a baby coming.
I know.
Wasn't she big time about like never again.
She did not like being pregnant.
I think she had a rough pregnancy.
That's awesome.
I don't think she liked any aspect of it.
Didn't she?
Not like newborn mass spec.
None of it.
I think she had a tough time transitioning into becoming a mommy.
But
no,
I had no idea.
Here I'll use the Google machine.
Tamar Google machine.
Yeah.
Only there was a way to figure these things out.
Pay More.
Braxton.
We are the Braxton
family.
Tom,
you,
Ooh,
same are pregnant with number two.
I think she is a cat.
It's hard to tell this.
Apparently she lashed out at somebody.
Let's see.
That's weird.
It's not like Tamar.
I know.
She lashed out at somebody who made fun of the way her son speaks.
Oh,
that's not cool.
Yeah.
Good for her.
I would do though.
She was saying that,
um,
somebody said he could use speech therapy.
Oh fuck them.
Don't say shit about people's kids.
Crazy.
So,
um,
we watched a movie last night.
We seldom get through films at this house.
Yeah.
But we watched a movie chark by Shark Bites.
It wasn't really,
it wasn't really called the shark bites.
It was called the shallows,
shallow hallows.
Shallow Halos.
I remember when it was out because I was at,
um,
I was on the road.
Sometimes people don't know,
but all we do is kill time throughout the day.
You went to the nerdy bar and I went to the titty bar and it was like seeing
enough tits for the day.
Well,
for flight.
I've seen enough tits.
Preflight,
sorry,
what now?
No,
but I remember the,
um,
the kid at a theatre box office kid was like trying to sell me on it.
He was like,
no,
I saw it.
It's really good.
Um,
I'll say this.
It was entertaining.
I loved it.
I mean,
look,
I wouldn't say you loved it cause I sat next to you and he were very critical.
You're like,
wow,
you are so critical in that mood behavior.
Because I was like,
number one,
you don't surf alone.
Everyone knows that.
Number two.
It's critical.
You were like,
that was the premise of the film though,
man.
You were like,
you were like a Tamar or at the movies.
You're like,
oh girl,
no.
I was like Jesus.
And you're like,
oh yeah.
Like that would happen.
Oh yeah,
like that shark would do that.
That's what that was due last night.
You don't even realize it.
I look for truth,
Tom.
We were real truth seeker.
Blake Blake lively,
that's her name.
And she's just hideous troll.
Have a blonde girl and her tits were in the movie too.
We really gross body gross face.
I mean,
what a bummer though.
The whole movie,
she's on a rock with her leg cut open.
Could you imagine filming that fucking nightmare of a movie or wet and cold all
day.
Every day.
What a nightmare for,
but she did a great job and the shark bites the shark.
Took a bite out of her and then she had to figure out how do I escape shark
bites.
Yeah,
it was scary.
That's right.
It was,
um,
it was real scary.
And she was in Mexico too.
So she,
you know,
another country.
There's shark bites.
There.
It is.
Yeah.
There it is.
She got her,
I think she got her titties that there really was,
there was some gross shit.
Um,
some of the shots were like,
oh my fucking pretty gnarly.
Yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
her body's terrible.
You know,
her lips got real chapter cause she was in the sun,
she stopped being attractive.
One of the few scenes was like,
well I'll turn off,
but then I feel like she found some chapstick in that buoy because then her lips
got smoothed out.
Smoothed out.
Yeah.
The Shark was real hungry.
He never satisfied.
Never.
He hung out for like two days with her dude.
But it was,
it was a fun movie.
I mean,
for,
there's Times I've killed me,
you know,
time,
90 minutes,
two hours,
and you're like,
this fucking sucked.
And it wasn't like that.
It wasn't a great movie,
but it was entertaining.
Think there's only so much shit this is going to happen.
You know,
the shark gets her or it doesn't,
and a story,
you know?
Yeah.
And it's an entertaining film.
We found one flaw in the film.
Oh yeah.
And this bothers me because I've,
I pointed it out
to you in other films,
primarily the Matt Damon,
the Martian,
the Martian movie where he's there for long time.
So he or she is,
um,
and the premise of the film,
I mean,
I think it's in the trailer.
Okay.
It's that she gets stuck at sea.
There's a shark looking for shark bites and anyways,
she's stuck on this rock first.
The whole day goes,
she gets bitten you and that's the price.
Yeah.
The whole day fucking goes by.
She doesn't masturbate once.
Right.
Then Day two comes,
she's cold,
she's bored,
she's tired,
she's bleeding,
she's in pain.
It doesn't masturbate again.
That's so true.
And then you're like,
I'm basically
saying that the hole is too big in this film.
It's a major premise flaw,
major premise flow.
She doesn't have any pornography to look at.
And she's not like,
oh,
I want to make myself feel like if I was ever there,
I want to feel good.
And I was basically about to dismiss this entire film.
And I don't mean to be a spoiler here,
but look at the end of the film when she gets on land,
she masturbates when she gets to land
the big gang bang scene where the guy's like,
hey,
you had a week laid down but open your mouth and then my son and I are going to
make sex with you.
Right.
I thought right after that they were like,
and she goes,
I didn't get off and they're like,
I don't care.
And then she masturbated.
Oh,
I missed that because the Martian,
I tried to have Tom Papa ask because he's friends with Matt Damon about whether
or not that was a conversation he didn't get back to.
He didn't know.
That did bother me about the Martian to lie to me about this one is it was two
full days and she didn't make a bowel movement.
Whereas the CEO doesn't shit off the rock.
Show me there's a masturbate.
Neither one really adds up.
Those are the holes I've seen.
The film,
the Martian is like,
you can't even defend that.
They're like,
they're either like texting him via satellites.
Like is there anything we can send you there?
Anything you want?
Like he wouldn't be like,
send me a picture of your tits are like,
I'm so hard.
I'm so backed up,
like never comes up.
And he was on the eye on the planet for a long time.
Really long time.
And he figured out how to grow food but he couldn't figure out how to download
porn.
Yeah.
Right.
Doesn't make sense.
Big Flaw.
Like you wouldn't be like,
oh my God,
cause he figured out food.
So once he knows he's got food and he's got life,
he knows he's going to live,
you'd be like,
oh you're,
you're basic needs are covered.
Right.
You're basic needs are water,
food and masturbation and like she's on that rock.
She's not going to like,
she knows like I'm on the Rock,
he's not going to get me.
I'm cold.
Yeah.
I wish I felt good.
What could make me feel good right now?
Right.
Oh can you just flick my been for a few minutes or water?
Probably masturbating before a water.
Yeah,
it was a priority.
Like if you were on that rock,
your priority list would probably be one masturbate too.
I'd probably,
you'd probably want to shave and zoom it three liters
mass in your own mouth.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah,
because you'd be hungry too.
So you have protein.
Uh,
uh,
they should have showed that on the Martian.
They should have shown that on the marsh versions.
So gross then
what's the proper way she doesn't have a cup?
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
She wouldn't have a semen.
That's Matt Damon,
right?
That's what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
So he should have just come into his own mouth is what you're saying you should
have.
Yeah,
of course.
He should have come down a lot of,
um,
Eh,
I've really been sorry,
go ahead.
No,
I was just saying that I've been,
I'm really enjoying your photograph of you wearing your perfect smile.
Yeah.
If an area's,
a lot of people are,
this is a really fun,
but you look really good in them.
I don't know what the secret is,
but they really,
they really fit in your mouth.
I feel like the perfect smile doesn't entirely fit my mouth.
But for you it was like tailor made.
Yeah.
Why do you think the secret is he's it?
Cause your gum color matches
the red of the perfect smile.
Um,
I don't know why.
but I uh,
I feel like he look at that.
That does look perfect.
That perfect smile is perfect.
I feel like it's just mouth size.
It's just real nice for me.
You look so third world with yours.
I just looked like a guy with a cool smile.
Okay.
That's the thing.
You actually do it looks okay
with your look that.
Huh?
What a cadaver.
You know who you look like?
The old man and Poulter guys too would sing.
God is in his holy Damn Paula or just any old person cause they always have fake
teeth.
Wait.
Okay.
Can I do it?
Yeah.
Don't put it in your mouth that you always do that wrong.
No,
no.
You just put it in your lips.
You always go too far in.
Yeah.
There you go.
Now it looks like it's your teeth.
I can do that laughing when I look at you though.
So,
so I can't have the perfect smile with even my life.
Um,
you
know,
there was huge news.
I probably got teed up by this for this like 100,000 times last week.
Heat up.
Yeah.
Like people reached out to me so much last week.
Oh my God.
I know too that
I've been living in Russia for like 50.
Steven Seagal is now a citizen of Russia.
Fucking defector.
Vladimir Putin himself named him a citizen and Seagal has been a really big
proponent of better relations with Russia.
Um,
for years now,
the last time I asked the CIA to provide me with people and answers,
they gave me people in answers that answered my questions the way they wanted it
to be answered,
meaning the CIA.
And the same with the State Department.
Dana knew that I knew the right people in Russia and he knew that I would get
them to tell him the truth.
And we all feel Dana and I feel that Russia and America have never fought each
other in a war.
We believe that Russia and America should be best friends.
Yeah.
But he also believes that I,
yeah.
Anyways,
go enjoy it.
Enjoy Russia.
Comrade,
comrade Seagal.
No official.
Go ahead.
If you love it,
so much fucking stay there.
Know I've been drinking.
Don't come back.
Do you a drink a vodka for that 63 years and uh,
I've been of an Eden Russian for rogies haven't even bro.
He's
74 years now.
Yeah.
Enjoy it.
Enjoy your,
your,
your Russian.
A winter and a well,
speaking of the Bird Chrysler of action films,
um,
nothing.
I got a uh,
another treat for you.
A new,
you gotta be kidding.
CIA trained.
This is the new Seagal trailer.
If you don't know,
there is nothing better than of the 12 or so films that Seagal releases a year
that,
uh,
are in the eight to $12,000 budget range.
The trailers are even better if it can be imagined.
Then the film,
it's a two minute trailer.
Wow.
That looks so real.
238 and to some people on board,
so I guess you're back
Islamic extremist.
These guys are attempting to form a of your life.
Here's the deal.
I get to wear my orange shades and I get to show up at any way I choose.
Okay.
And my Kimono,
what is he wearing?
His Geek.
And you got to spend at least 10 grand on this movie.
All right?
All right.
Cartels has got to be active as it.
Nobody knows nobody.
There's someone to be reckoned with,
a covert mission.
And my cousins got to do the narration on the trailer.
I want mine.
Never even seen a film like this.
An elite team.
You're most pick John Harmon might have a job propose
we like,
can we give him a box of chocolate?
We don't really count
whispering all of his lines in this film or you don't know.
Steve has been doing for awhile now.
You didn't know that.
He's so lazy.
He's whispering.
Is that his dialogue now?
Yeah,
he's been,
um,
it's,
it's sort of like the school he comes from,
you know,
uh,
acting the whisper school with preschool,
the squint school.
I mean,
there's things about it and lot of people don't.
When I am the king of in province for,
for you.
I am.
I mean I think people would go wow if will Ferrell said that.
Yeah.
But Steven said it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's my job stopped
it
don't pay to six on my count.
Three,
two,
one game on a global threat.
There's a yellow card.
Now
the chill come into it.
No,
it's,
you don't see a lot of body shots.
Right.
And it's dark like shoulders.
Yeah.
Especially I'm saying the whole film is shot by candlelight cause he looks,
he gotta be two 85 to 99 lease.
Yeah.
No,
that's too much.
I don't understand what the fuck is.
Do you understand what's happening?
No.
I mean,
yes.
Uh,
if there was your back and he goes,
I need my own team and my own gear and then there's just shit.
Hello?
So they went with that new,
uh,
hey,
this guy used to be where they will know and he's back
switch to play.
They don't think a decimeter USC seconds.
Okay.
You think that director ever says,
could you emote something?
Can you,
could you,
you know what's so funny?
I was,
he got to the face of this and he also does anything.
They basically,
he doesn't really say that I with me.
Right.
Well what I was just thinking to myself is what does he bring to the table
because he's not active anymore.
He's not kinky punching.
He's certainly is phoning in the acting.
I think they know there's enough of a market,
like he's a big enough name where someone like there's enough people out there
that are willing to pay something to see these films for dollars.
Not the um,
your,
you know,
your movie goer of today or somebody who's like this.
Probably a lot of people here who are,
you know,
a few that like old action.
But
then in other countries where he's still a big deal,
right.
My,
my step Dad,
my Indian step dad liked his movie course.
My stepdad probably would,
would watch this.
Your Dad came to the country a few years later,
he would have made his name Steven.
Right?
It's true.
Yeah.
True.
Cause they had the same hair.
They're the same.
They did.
That's how my Stepdad and new to dye his hair nice and easy black because this
is a real nice and easy,
just was such a nice and easy job.
Yeah.
Did you punch him?
We just saw the budget right there.
That was a whole budget say besides a little more budget than the,
um,
well,
I mean that has a little kicky punching,
but yeah,
a lot of editing.
Okay.
Well he's no longer American to me,
so this is a cute movie.
Accepted Russian citizenship.
It's so,
it's so gross.
Um,
go live there.
Go live with it really is like his six film of the year,
which is incredible.
Yeah.
He's like the Woody Allen of the action world.
Perfect smile.
Um,
yeah,
he's a
okay.
He's really,
he's really a fucking,
not a cool guy.
But anyways,
I'm just not a fan.
Um,
let me give you moved to North Korea.
I don't show
the commies.
Check this out.
America is a PSA,
isn't it?
Kid?
Bundles of energy,
but they need the right snacks to keep them going.
That's why I give my kids pretty bad.
Saw that one.
Venting trips around your home can be as easy as tidying up toys.
That was pretty good.
That was pretty funny.
That was horrifying
part.
Yeah.
I don't like that bit.
Okay,
nice.
I don't want to see it again.
Those horrible preventing trips around your home is easy as tidying up toys.
Okay.
This is a good one for us.
No Shit.
Our whole world is,
yeah,
toy city.
Great.
Well thanks for sending that in.
A couple of big reminders before we leave you.
Um,
most terrible.
Do you want,
um,
oh,
let's remind people.
Yeah.
Bert Kreischer the machine pro premiers November 11th at 10:00 PM on showtime on
demand the next day.
Um,
me,
your,
your main mommy.
I'm in Louisville,
Kentucky this weekend.
Um,
the new water champ shirt is on sale now.
Get it for Christmas for your loved ones.
Yeah.
Go to the store and go to Thomson Jr.
Com.
Click on the story.
Your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on the store a thousand ranch.com Amazon.
Please do your Christmas shopping.
Yes.
Using our banner,
your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on the banner at the bottom,
the homepage to your shopping.
He's all right.
Uh,
we have to,
my brain.
Does this ever smash down on your skull and make it hurt?
I think that's too tight.
Yeah.
Hurts me.
I shouldn't smash on your brain.
This is a song of closing song by Dj boy butter.
It's called retarded.
Chris Jane's a thank you boy butter.
I like that.
Yeah.
Well I've not heard it,
so let's hear it.
Thanks for listening and we'll see you next week.
Bye Jeans
a lot there.
Oh,
when you're Puerto Rican,
you're just Puerto Rican.
What's input?
Like,
I've always wanted to kind of pick it apart.
Hey,
you guys tableau Maaco Shit.
And you're like,
it's like getting masturbated by a child,
right?
The mother of your baby with your retarded tips,
shooting retarded milk into him,
giving him retard juice every day.
Amy,
I'm going to come when he's stone and I
share.